Running apps in virtual machines
means that they're essentially
sandboxed in runtime.
This means that the apps cannot directly
interfere with the operating system and
other apps.
Nor can they directly
access the device hardware.
Each app is granted a set of
permissions at install time, and
cannot perform operations that
require permissions it does not have.
More specifically, the Android platform
takes advantage of the Linux user-based
protection as a means of identifying and
isolating application resources.
The Android system assigns
a unique user ID, or UID,
to each Android app and runs it as
that user in a separate process.
The kernel enforces
security between apps and
the system at the process level
through standard Linux facilities
such as user and
group IDs that are assigned to the apps.
By default,
apps cannot interact with each other and
apps have limited access
to the operating system.
If app A tries to do something
malicious like reading app B's data or
downloading the form without permission,
then the operating system protects
against this, because app A does not
have the appropriate user privileges.
This sandbox model is simple, but
on the other hand, it is based on
decades of Unix style user separation
of processes and file permissions.
An app can announce
the permissions that it needs, and
user approval is required
at install time.
The permissions are typically, back up.
The permissions
are typically implemented
by mapping them to Linux groups that
have the necessary read-write access to
relevant system resources,
such as files and sockets.
And therefore, they are ultimately
enforced by the Linux kernel.